Okay, first question. Do you have a protocol for fibromyalgia?
No, no. So, the reason why it all, because there's reasons why a person would have the symptoms
of fibromyalgia, fibromyalgia is not a disease in itself.
fibromyalgia is a collection of symptoms. It's a syndrome. So you have to figure out why a person
has this collection of symptoms. Do they have an autoimmune issue? So they have antibodies to
self-tissue. Very common. They have antibodies to collagen. They have antibodies to their
upper motor neuron, brain issue. So, running labs that will look for antibodies to self-tissue
would be in order. Also with fibromyalgia, you could have some sort of chronic infection, chronic
Lyme type issue, can be an issue with fibromyalgia. So you don't want to, and I'd recommend this
with, but just about everything, there's, you don't want to go to somebody who's just going to,
here's my fibromyalgia protocol, or here's this protocol for this disease. I'm not saying
somebody might not be helped by that, but you have to get to the reason why. You always got to
dig to the reason why and try to figure that out, and then treat the reason why. You got
treating the name disorder or name syndrome or name disease.
Fortunately, that is really what is happening in the practice of medicine. No, I mean, everybody's just
a disease. So the idea of medicine is we come to the name of the disease, and then we look up
and work manual, no, electronically, and we give this drug for that disease. Well, is it treating
the reason why the disease is there? No, it's not typically treating why the disease is there. It's
not addressing the reason why. Well, are you helping the patient? Well, the drug may effectively
decrease that person's symptoms, but just because you've decreased the person's symptoms doesn't mean
that you've effectively helped that person with overall morbidity and issues with mortality for
that disease. I don't know. I think it's best to look and try to dig into a figure out the reason why.
Next question. What are supplements to support the mitochondria? What are vitamins that help
live disease? This is multi-question here. So I don't typically read these questions before I get
them in. What are the best probiotics for someone with reoccurring vaginal infections, or UTI,
or both? What's the best cellular detox supplements? Oh, or questions in one. So first of all,
best questions to support the mitochondria, best supplements to support the mitochondria.
Again, if a person has mitochondrial issues, so they may have, so what does the mitochondria do? The
mitochondria is really responsible for making energy for the body. So the mitochondria you create
ATP. So ATP is energy that is needed for that cell that is needed for the body. So if the mitochondria
has dysfunction, and there's a lot of books out there that talk about different diseases, our mitochondrial
diseases. Cancer is a metabolic disease. Talks about dysfunction in the mitochondria. So
chronic fatigue, you know, people point to, well, it's the mitochondria. You're not making
enough energy, but even with that, you've got to figure out why. So before we start just throwing
supplements, this is going to help mitochondrial function. So we're going to support it with this
supplement. You have to find out why you have, if you truly do have mitochondrial dysfunction,
and then why you have mitochondrial dysfunction, it's all that. There's many reasons why a person
can have mitochondrial dysfunction. And one can be toxins, one, you know, heavy metals, all sorts of
the things that could interrupt mitochondria's ability to make energy. But it's much bigger than that.
A person can have energy issues that are tied to mitochondrial function at all. They're tied to
adenia. They have energy issues that are tied to chronic inflammation. You have to have energy
issues that are tied to hypothyroidism. You could have energy issues that are tied to a lot of
different things. So it's again digging to the reason why. And I don't want to disappoint everybody,
but I'm not going to be a doctor that's just going to say just take this or this symptom
because you're not finding out why. So you've got to dig to that. And there are some labs that
you could do to figure that out. I got to have this on the holistic health out, or about digging
to the reason why, because it is so important to really achieve ultimate success in anything you're
doing. If you go look at our website, cuttersclinic.com, you could go up on the upper tab where it says
courses. Our best course to take for these overall health issues is the chronic disease
and autoimmune course where I go into great depth through that course on why you should run
certain labs, why you should do certain tests to figure out and what you would find on that test.
And what you would look for on that test, how you would best interpret that test to find out the
reasons why I have an issue. So that chronic disease and autoimmune course is going to be your best
thing to do to look at that. Even if you're working with a functional medicine doctor now,
maybe he or she doesn't have as much time clinically to explain the result. Maybe you're running some
of these labs. Maybe they don't have the time to explain these labs in great detail to you.
Well, I created videos on that course. So I did it so that my patients I could just say go to
you know module two of the product disease course. I know you're on that. Watch some of the labs on
blah blah blah. And watch some of the videos on this subject because that saves me time.
If you do not be charged per for my time to explain this to you, when you could go watch a 12 minute
video and explain it to you, then you can watch it two times if you do. So that's the thing to do.
Next part of this question. What are vitamins that help Lyme disease?
Again, there's really three stages of Lyme disease. So if a person is in stage one,
stage one is defined by the fact that you person just got the tick bite. So you're just infected with
an acute bacterial infection, Borrelia, Nurgadorphe is the bacteria in Lyme disease. But I know there's
multiple different bacteria and viruses that are co-infections that go along with Lyme disease.
But so when I say Lyme disease, I'm talking about Nurgadorphe and the multiple co-infection. So
person just gets Lyme disease. You cannot kill the viral component
except by through your own immune system function. But you can kill the bacterial component when it's
still in the blood, still in the tissues, but it has not yet traversed to go inside of a cell.
So if it's still in the tissues, still in the blood, you can kill the bacterial component of Lyme disease
with an antibiotic. So I always recommend that if you have acute Lyme disease, which I call stage one
Lyme disease, you use an antibiotic. You use antibiotic therapy to kill it. That's going to be your
best bet. Problem is, is that many times you won't catch it, but it's still in phase one. Again,
phase one is defined as the bacteria has not yet gone intracellular inside of a cell.
You might just have the symptoms of Lyme disease, which are like flu-like symptoms. And
you go to a doctor and you say, hey, I was outside. I got bitten by a tick. Maybe you did. Maybe you
didn't find the tick on your body member. It's a deer tick, not just a regular wolf tick. And you
maybe had a bullseye rash. Maybe didn't have a bullseye rash. Regardless, you may end up with a doctor who
won't prescribe an antibiotic without getting a Lyme blood test, which I think is foolishness.
Find a different doctor that will prescribe based upon symptoms, based upon signs other than labs.
The reason is, is if you get the blood test and you wait a week to get that blood test back,
it may have already progressed into phase two, meaning that the bacteria has gone intracellular.
So as long as you have one bacteria that goes inside the cell, you have the chance of not being
able to kill it all through using an antibiotic. If you catch it truly in phase one, you use an
antibiotic nine times out of 10, you're going to be able to knock it out of your system. And you're
not going to be worried about taking vitamins for it because you have killed it with an antibiotic.
Now taking other vitamins and nutrition that will stimulate and immune response at that point
are beneficial because the viral component. So we have a product called
acute LX, which I created specifically for that acute phase line. But that isn't the substitute
for an antibiotic. So I still recommend that you get an antibiotic in that situation. If you go
to a doctor that says we need to get a blood test before I could give you an antibiotic, go to
another doctor immediately, try to get an antibiotic for that situation because you may miss it.
Once it goes into phase two, once the bacteria goes intracellularly, then it can start reproducing
inside the cell and create a chronic disorder. So once it's in a chronic disorder, then it's more
difficult to kill it within an antibiotic because antibiotics don't go intracellularly and it won't
kill the bacteria when it's inside the cell. So it will replicate inside the cell and then come
outside the cell and right again and go into the tissue. That's what antibiotics can work. That's where
long-term antibiotic use can be beneficial for those with chronic Lyme disease, phase two Lyme disease.
The problem is long-term antibiotic use wreaks havoc on the rest of the body in your gut system,
etc. Then there's also a phase three Lyme disease where your body has now made antibodies against
cell tissue because this bacteria is continuing to go inside and outside the cell. Your immune system
is trying to kill it and then your B cell response of your immune system can then create antibodies
against cell tissue. So you now have antibodies against cell tissue. You now have an autoimmune
disease. Chronic infections like Lyme, chronic infections like Epstein Bar, and things like that are
are known to be a major trigger to stimulate an autoimmune disease to disease. To something that
trigger to an autoimmune disease is something that the immune system is unable to kill for various
reasons and that it creates antibodies to cell tissue where it's found that bacteria. Now you have
antibodies to your own cells. That's the definition of an autoimmune disease. Once you have autoimmune
disease, phase three Lyme, or an autoimmune disease, of any kind whatsoever. So you have antibodies
to self tissue and you have no idea what caused it. That you're in a whole nother
game and you absolutely need to get that chronic disease in autoimmune course because you should not
be taking any immune stimulants long-term immune stimulants if you have self antibodies. That goes
more if I have a long term if I have Hashimoto's, well that's antibodies to the thyroid gland. You
should not be taking long-term immune stimulants. You should only use immune stimulants in a cute
based reaction. So a lot to know there. I spoke quickly but that's all in our Lyme course and our
autoimmune course. What are the best probiotics for someone with reoccurring vaginal tract
infections, UTI infections? One of the best probiotics. Well, I always suggest that you
alternate probiotics. I know there's more and more science coming up coming out about specific
probiotics for specific issues and specific biomes of your body, microbiomes of your body. However,
I think it's best to alternate probiotics. I also think that you're not going to cure your problem
by taking probiotics. So it's not so much a probiotic deficiency meaning I need to take
one type of probiotic short of solving my problem. One of the probiotics that you get in a capsule
of probiotics compared to what you get in your food and a variety of different foods is not even
comparable. So it's really more so what's your eating? If I'm getting chronic, recurrent, UTIs,
you need to dig a little deeper to figure out the why. So there can be different triggers,
different food sensitivities, different chemical sensitivities that are causing these things.
Hormone disruptors can cause these things too. So you need to dig to why. I don't
while this is a good and valid question, I don't want to mislead somebody that you're just like one
supplement away or one probiotic away from from solving my problem. You've got to dig to why it's
there in the first place. Just saw an article really interesting that came out about
these tighter slacks that gals are wearing more today. These yoga type things. They did a study
and they found the chemical that was in them is such a high concentration of hormone
disruption chemical. And this is right here. Your vaginal tract that you're wearing these tight pants.
And then you could think, well, that makes me think about underwear. That makes me think about other
things that I'm putting on my body. The creams, lotions, all this kind of stuff has chemicals in it.
That is hormone, not only hormone disruptor. What is that doing to my body? What is that
causated and mutory action in my body? Major issues. Those are the things that you want to dig in with
recurrent infections of any kind. What are the best cellular detox supplements? Part four of this question.
Well, I think when you talk about cellular detox, you talk about you're talking about what I call
phase zero detoxification pathway. I list this out in my 7 phases of detox book and my 7 phases of
detox video and my 7 phase of detox course. I don't want to be just thinking I'm trying to upsell
you guys on everything, but there's a lot of information in these courses and there's a lot of
information that we need to know about the physiology of a question like this. I'm going to try to
go quickly on this. You have really 7 phases of detoxification. Let's start with the end. The end is
you deposit things in the toilet. I call that phase six. If you're constipated or you're not having
good bowel movements, you have no business trying to detox cellularly until you get that cleared up.
And then phase five is what is your intestinal rate of elimination? What is your elimination rate?
Meaning if I eat corn today, do I see it in my stool tomorrow? If it takes three days to see it in my
stool, my intestinal transit time is extremely slow. If I am a intestinal transit time that's slow,
even though I might have daily bowel movements, I'm reabsorbing a lot of poisons in my intestinal
tracks, particularly the large intestine. If I am reabsorbing my poisons in the large intestine
because my intestinal transit time is slow, I'm diffuting the purpose of everything as far as detoxification.
So I have to make sure my intestinal transit time is healthy. So I'm not eating it and have to run
into the bathroom. I have diarrhea. But I'm eating it and noticing what I ate that is indigestible,
an indigestible starchy fiber that I ate in the toilet in my feces the next day. I should have
that. That should be the intestinal transit time, the rate of what's going through my gut.
That I call phase five. So if I'm reabsorbing poisons in my gut, then I need to deal with that before
I have any business of trying to pull stuff out of my tissues. And then the phase four is how
is the health of my gallbladder itself. So my gallbladder itself, we could even include my pay
grace health in that. How is the health of that? Is that sluggish? If that's sluggish, I need to deal
with that. So again, I go into greater detail in my book and my course, my detox course on this.
And then phase three, two and one is in the liver. That's what you'd read about in your physiology book.
If you've taken, if you remember biology, human biology, if you've taken a course of that, you'll read
a phase one, two and three that takes place in the liver. So blood goes through the liver and then
through phase one detoxification pathway, it pulls toxins out of the blood and it goes through phase one,
then phase two, phase three, it's bound to bile. It goes into the gallbladder, that's phase four,
and into the smaller test, and phase five, hopefully you're not reabsorbing anything of phase six,
you're deposited into the toilet. So how does it get into the blood? Well, it gets into the blood,
first, by you consuming it or you breathing it in a toxic that goes directly into the blood.
Hopefully it's going to get filtered right out of the liver. The problem is that you have congestion
in the liver, slow phase one, two, three pathways, overwhelmed phase one, two, three pathways.
So it circulates again, it circulates again, then finally we'll get dumped into the tissue and then
commonly gets absorbed into a fat cell and do your cells. You can go into any cell, but fat cells,
I always say have the spiritual gift of accommodation, they welcome anybody in, they take in a lot of
toxins, but it can go into any cells, and then toxins can cause damage to the nucleus, and
the damage to the nucleus can be answered. That's what cancer is, is the nucleus replication rate,
replication, replicating cells, that's cancer. Have to make sure our DNA
is the thought is, well, go to six out of my cells, that's all that phase zero,
how you would use a part of your cells, you'd use it later. So, key later,
TTA, DMSL, there's a lot of different, but you have no business doing that if your
phase two, phase three in the liver, because it'll just get dumped somewhere else. So, when you're
healing the gut, you're from the top down, when you're much slower than I did right here, and that's
how you would eventually then pull stuff out. Next question, hi, my 71-year-old husband had two
days put in his heart, oh, day, aspirin, 81 milligrams, and another medication. However,
this makes him have bruises and bleed easily, especially after shall we're even even before
taking any blood titters. He seemed to easily bruise and bleed. One concern also is that in the past,
he has had high H-pilory levels in ulcers, and as it is in his digestion, as his digestion
is a bit delicate, so would there be any advice on how to counteract any possible internal bleeding
or ill effects of bleeding elsewhere? Well, you have to follow the prescribed doctors' recommendations
as far as that medication. I can't legally tell you to do anything differently with the medication,
but the doctor should be able to run some tests to see what his need is for that and how long he
needs to be on that, and he should be addressing these other comorbidities. Now, you cannot be taking
things also supplement-wise that are also blood titters, so be careful of that. And unfortunately,
one of a good supplement to help kill H-pilory in garlic, and garlic is probably the number one
supplemental blood titters, so you cannot be taking garlic if you're taking blood titters and you're
already having bleeding issues. As far as trying to heal a bleeding ulcer, that's totally different.
You shouldn't really be trying to kill H-pilory with, like I said, anything that's going to thin blood.
Burberry does another great killer of H-pilory, but one thing to help heal a bleeding ulcer can be,
well, there's different products out there. We have a product called Clear GI. It's got slippery
elm. It's got a lot of different herbs, okra, and glutamine to help heal the gut. So there's a lot of
good healing products out there, as long as he doesn't have cancer, he can definitely go on a product
like that. So you do want to help heal any bleeding ulcer. You do want to also look for discolouration
stools, because that will be a side of bleeding, an internal bleed, and your doctor should be informed.
The doctor who has prescribed this should be informed exactly all of the morbidity so that they can
properly manage the medication. Ok, I want to become a professional in the field of naturopathic medicine.
Where do I start? Good question. I want to become a professional that too. That sounds fun.
Ok, so where would you start? Well, it depends on what you want to do. So if you want to do
carpractic, then you just have to go to carpractic school. If you want to be a naturopath that
can be licensed in certain states, then you have to go to a four-year naturopathic school.
There are a lot of online courses for naturopathic information and for learning how to take care of
people. There's pros and cons to that. So on these holistic health hours and on some of my videos,
I've shared some of my distaste struggles that I have on social media all that much, but
lots of times when I'm on, I'll see videos of corticote naturopaths or some of them are even doctors.
So it's even some people that are even doctors that are shared advice, natural advice that
that I don't think is right. And so that kind of bothers me sometimes. Like, ok,
was this person, he's not saying he's a doctor or she's a doctor, but they're
to natural healing. I don't know, maybe they're selling natural products. I'm not judging their
education, but when they're sharing things that are wrong, you're going to be careful of that.
I don't know. I just feel like there's huge benefits. Learning physiology and anatomy.
So before you start learning some natural healing methods, and there's a balance there too.
So just taking some online naturopathic type things can be beneficial because you could
help a lot of people and you could help yourself. So I'm not saying that there's anything wrong with
that. But you do have to temper your education with constantly learning physiology because a lot of
things that I see videos are like, ok, one big thing that one of the naturopathic schools teach
is that you need to localize yourself. And there's books written, there's books written on these
subjects that are totally physiologically wrong. And that bothers the daylights out of me sometimes
because people get led down to a pathway that's just incorrect. And that's big in the cancer realm.
So we need to, you need to localize yourself. Cancer can't grow in an alkaline environment. How
many times have you heard that in a natural realm? These are just, they're not true. Cancer, yes,
it is a highly metabolic state where your cells are in rapid replication as I shared. And it's
going to spew out a lot of waste in doing so. And that's going to be acidic. And it can be a kind
of a slime layer around the growing cancer. And you do want to alkalize that and get in that and
break that up. But you can't alkalize that by drinking alkaline water. Put a six, there's even
alkaline water machines. There's alkaline water on the market. You could go in a fancy grocery store
probably by alkaline water. People pay exorbit prices for this stuff to drink. You know, pH of
nine water. Let's just think about that from a physiological perspective. It makes no sense. Your
stomach is supposed to have a pH of about two. And you're putting high alkaline water in there.
What's going to happen? You think that alkaline water is now going to go into your small intestine
still with a pH of nine. And it's going to be absorbed as water with a high pH.
Does it make any sense physiologically? How do you alkalize something in the first place? Put a
bunch of minerals in it. Now it's alkaline. Well, that's great. What's the stomach have to do with that?
The stomach has to acidify it. So you're having to acidify that alkaline substance that's coming into
your body. Well, your stomach does that all the time. Hopefully if you have proper amount of HCl
produced by the stomach cells, then you're going to acidify that. But you've actually done no good
by drinking alkaline water to think but your drinking alkaline water is going to alkalize your breast
cancer. It just it makes no physiological sense. And I I'm trying to teach people through my courses
to start thinking, to start understanding some basic physiology so that you could think through
this ago. That's not right. And if you could get your little physiology spice at this up to catch
these things, you're going to be better off for that. Do the people that sell this stuff know it's
a scam? I don't know. Maybe they totally believe it. And I know there's people out there maybe
listening right now and say, no way. I was helped where I started drinking my alkalized water.
It's probably because you started drinking more water. I don't know. I don't know. But I know that it
wasn't because of the alkalinity of the substance you were drinking. So how do you alkalize the body?
Well, first of all, that's not what your purpose is to do is to alkalize the body. Your purpose is to
eat good food to make sure that you're you're low in the inflammatory scale to investigate whether
food that you are eating you already have antibodies. You don't already have antibodies against this
causing inflammation, even if it's good food. And you're trying to heal, you know, what you have
desis needs to heal. So it's just so how did I get off on that? We talk about what education I should seek
because you can't learn a lot of these things from, you know, schools that are out there. But I
but there's a lot of bad information too. So it's hard to direct you in the right direction. If you're
wanting to go through college and spend a whole bunch of money and go through a good naturopathic
college, that's your best bet. You know, it's going to take a lot longer. You're looking at eight years
of education. You're looking at hundreds of thousands of dollars of education. That's going to be
your best bet. But you can there's online naturopathic, you know, courses that you could take for a couple
thousand dollars, as long as you're willing to really dig and study and learn physiology and learn
human anatomy. I think you can learn a lot of this on your own. So it's just how invested you're
going to be and really be good at what you do. And I think that's the key. Honestly, I've known a lot
of doctors and I've taught a lot of doctors too over the years that sometimes we're just there to make
money and it's like they're not really invested in really studying and really going this stuff.
So it depends on you and your heart really because I guess you could spend several hundred thousand
or eight years of education to just be as kind of a some part doctor too. So it really depends on
you and how willing you are to dig into this. I don't have another life. I don't play golf. I don't
do anything else. I guarded and I study. That's about it. I'm not a very fun person to be around.
But you know, I think you have to be dedicated to what God has called you to. I believe this is my
calling. I don't do this because I like it. It's half the time I don't. It's because I feel like I'm
called to it. So you just keep studying. Try to keep learning. You get good metrics.
Next question. Can using the right for cancer cause an increase in inflammation
while it works to fight the cancer? That is a good question. I call this tab real quick
because see if any of the questions came in. So can using the right cause for cancer increase
inflammation while it works to fight the cancer? Yes it can. So using the right was using frequency
technology through light waves to stimulate the body to fight this cancer. Well what part of the
body is fighting cancer? It's your immune system. And your immune system does so by creating an
acute inflammatory response. That's what your immune system does. So while I thought inflammation
is bad. Well yes, chronic inflammation is bad. That's a chronic inflammatory response
with chronic cytokine up regulation. But you want an acute inflammatory response at the site
of a cancer to kill the cancer just like you want an acute inflammatory response when you have
an acute bacterial infection or a viral infection. So it's not uncommon when a person is using a
rife and it's programmed correctly for that person's cancer that that around that cancer there can
be inflammation. If there's inflammation elsewhere in the body, then that's an issue. You do want to
look for possible antibodies. You want to look for possible autoimmune issues. But if there's just
inflammation at the cancer, then that can be a good good thing. I have a post on my website where I
think a video is contained on a tube where I talk about cancer, good pain versus bad pain. Because
a person when you're fighting cancer, whether you're using a rife or proper nutrition to fight
cancer, you have an inflammatory response. Depending on where that cancer is in your body,
that increase inflammation could increase pain because it's going to occupy space. So look at
that good pain, bad pain video on our website. Do symptoms seem to fluctuate when you are early on
and using the rife using between better and worse? Yes, and that is a better side if that
if the symptoms are fluctuated because your immune response isn't just constant. It will be a
hyper immune response, killing things that will die off and hyper immune response, killing things
that die on. It's not a common also to get a pseudo enlargement of a tumor when you're properly
killing it as well. We need even an MRI CT scan or a PET scan. It can look like it's an increased
size because of the inflammation that's going on around the cancer, killing the cancer. So be
aware of that as well. Next question. 54 years old have had herpes for 32 years, now constant outbreaks.
In fact, 43 outbreaks since January 1st of this year. If I eat most any carb, even through it can
break me out. Of course, food tie and arginate, nuts and seeds and grades can just eat one or two
nuts and break out. So I avoid them as much as possible, but sometimes I crave them. I have done
everything imaginable. Early on I tried Zorix and had terrible side effects, since then I've done
lysine peroxide, monolore, the regular one, something that parasite cleanses long-term,
consistent red heat lamp, sonar, castor oil packs, coffee animals, grade retraction,
full-time gene life frequencies and on and on of annulorous lamps was diagnosed with MCAS two
years ago and which I have uncovered mold, lime, strep, hemstein bar along with this. I've worked
on, got liver, got root cells taken out, you, David, just can't imagine how to break the code.
I know I am missing some lamps that may help me. Any suggestions?
Well, there's no way I can uncover that ball of wax on a platform like this. So we need to dig in.
I mean, if you really want me to help you, you're going to have to make a case, do a case reveal
and we're going to have to kind of get going on a planet attack of some different investigation.
So when a person is hypersensitive to anything and it causes a flare somewhere else in their body,
so in this case, it's causing a herpes flare. So herpes is a virus that lives in the nerve
ganglion. So, for instance, like herpes in your mouth, it lives in the trigeminal nerve ganglion.
That's a ganglion of nerves right up here from cradle nerve 5. And then that will come out in your
mouth when there's an opportunistic time. Usually with herpes in the mouth, it has to do with the
pH change of your mouth. You suck on a lemon and you get a colesor, kind of often people end up with that.
So it's because that drastically changed the pH of the mouth and the
immune response went down and the virus just migrated right down the nerve pathway and erupted
in the lip or wherever. Same thing with genital herpes, it's a virus that you really,
and a lot of these viruses, you can never kill them. You can't kill them. There's no immune
magic. There's no right frequencies that can completely kill them because there's debate whether
they're leaving even living organisms, right? So there you have to learn how to manage them.
So with management of that, you're going to find the different triggers. So you think, well,
it's that food, that's the trigger, that's the trigger. Well, even if you know, okay, it's not food
that triggers, it can be an underlining core trigger. So it's some inflammation that's going on
in the gut that is that you're at this hyper response, meaning that you're right below threshold.
So anything is just constantly just tipping you over. So you have to figure out what are some
other core triggers that are keeping your immune system at that hyper response just below
threshold. So not always get an outbreak, but then anything just sets me off. Anything just
tips me over. So you got to figure those things out and clean those things out. It can be complicated.
And it is a mess. And I understand it is extremely frustrating. But you can't give up on yourself.
You just got to keep digging. Next question, dear Dr. Cutters, we're looking for stomach ulcer help.
The cause of this could be because of recently added medications,
can hydrochloric acid with meals have an adverse effect and cause pain. Any thoughts if you
use a cholesterol pack over stomach will be helpful in other tips. Okay, so if you take HCl and it
causes pain, that's a real good chance. So if you're not tolerant to HCl because of pain,
real good chance you already have stomach damage or you have an ulcer. You have an active ulcer.
You have to back off and go to acetic acid. So taking an apple cider vinegar, you need to
acidify the stomach because it's the it's the lack of acid in the stomach that has caused the ulcer
because remember ulcers are caused from HCl. He'll go back to Pylora and he'll go back to Pylora
is caused because a decreased stomach acid 9 times 10. So if you had proper stomach acid in the
first place, never would have got HPylora, never would have got a stomach ulcer. So you've got to
back up and do that. But going right to HCl causing irritation, you may have to heal the stomach first.
Go to our website Cuttersclinics.co.nz, ursclinic.com search HPylora or he'll go back to Pylora.
I have a whole sequence of events and videos on how to do this correctly. If you have adverse reaction
to HCl, you start with apple cider vinegar. If you can't even tolerate apple cider vinegar,
you got to heal the stomach in the first place and you could use things like we talked about before,
deglycerized licorice, you could use okra, you could use glutamate, you could use so we have a
product called clear GI that can be helpful, it's a powdered form. You've got to heal the stomach,
you've got to take a few weeks to heal the stomach or if not always the stomach, it's the
one and the two you could have ulceration even in the swallow tested elsewhere. So you've got to
heal the gut and then you keep trying tolerance to apple cider vinegar, tell you could tolerate that
with the meal and then you add and you're tolerating to spine, a couple of tables with apple cider vinegar
prior to meal, then you try HCl and you have to up the doses of HCl and I share a video on how to do
that so that will help you walk through that pathway to try to to heal your gut, rebalance your
hydrochloric acid production in your stomach and to eventually work on killing HCl. I use it,
we have a product called ParaClear, we have Burberry products out there that can be extremely helpful
to kill HCl. Remember with HCl, it is the number one bacterial infection worldwide
according to the World Health Organization and it is highly contagious, but you'll spread it
easily so if somebody in your family has HCl, most likely you do too. So what's best is when I have
patients that have HCl, I say it's best that everybody in the family takes Burberry or ParaClear product,
maybe they don't have to take the same dosage as you do, but it's something good to take. I personally
take Burberry all the time, I take ParaClear not every day, but at least once a week because HCl
is just everywhere. In HCl, we said it causes stomach ulcers and issues, but it is also the
number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide and it goes systemic. It is the cause of rosacea,
it's a cause of a lot of skin rashes that go undiagnosed, it's the cause of, it's one of the top four
causes of corduary heart disease. So H by lower I get under the anothelial layer, that's the
single layer of epithelial cells that that coat the inside of your arteries. If it's underneath that
anothelial layer and can attack the smooth muscles, it could be the major player of high blood pressure
and it is definitely a major player and etchied of the arteries along with whole assisted and causes
cholesterol patched. So cholesterol gets the bad guy, but it's actually H by lower I, that is
commonly the root cause and you need to address that. I wonder if, next question, what are if
deglycerized licorice, D-G-L is okay to take while on PPI's. So PPI is a protein pump inhibitor.
If you're on a PPI, pretty much guaranteed U-M-H by lower. So why did you go on a PPI? Well,
because I had reflux and all sorts of reflux and my doctor said that I should just go on a PPI
because I could get some, I could get the soft agel etchied and I could end up with soft agel cancer.
Tell you, PPI is like poison, you know, I'm sorry. There's some drugs that are like,
you could be on the rest of your life, it is probably going to have no ill effects, be it on
scintoroid or something like that. Really, you tolerate it well, you're not going to have any issues
with that. Ever. It's a good drug. Be it out of PPI, bad drug. Never was a good drug. It was,
you realize, Steve, in this day, it was only supposed to be used for like 21 days, I think,
back to them. But people have PPI's for years, horrible for you. You want to end up with,
I mean, you could be on a PPI for just a sharp ear type and you're going to end up with H, with H kind of
or more realistically, because you went on a PPI, it was because you had, you had a decrease HCl
and process quite possibly H, PPI. So I can't legally tell you to go off a PPI. You need to deal with
that with your prescribed doctor, but you need to deal with the reason why. This is another,
you said, the other thing that, you know, I held in this course is, you know, you just give a
person the drug, take care of the symptoms. It's just to me that's not the practice of medicine.
That is the practice of current medicine. That's not the practice of health care. It was giving
this drug to make the symptoms go away. Well, that'd be great. You know, that's like hitting your
head with a hammer and I'm going to give you an aspirin so the pain goes away, but to keep your head
with the hammer. Okay, that's that's kind of what's going on with that. So I hate to be
mean, but I need to be sometimes, that's just wrong. I don't want to be mean to the person who's
taken a PPI. You don't know, but you need to learn. So go to our website, look up our blogs for HPyLore,
HCl, look at the videos on that. I have a bunch of videos on our course on that as well. Okay,
good talk. I think we're done with our questions for today. And remember to go to our holistic health
hour website and you can post your questions right out there. You'll see a place, a box. I think
if the blue box on that website where you can ask the question that will more surely get the question
answered on this talk, plus each one of these holistic health hours are nicely indexed on that
website. So you could go ahead and see what you're looking for. Also look at our website,
cuttersclinic.com. They have a well over 1,000 blog posts and I highly recommend that you
join our courses. Good as safe. It's $50 for a course. That's too much money. You don't really
invested in your health care. Sorry to shave you, but you need to learn this stuff because if you don't
learn this stuff, nobody else is going to teach you. holistichealthhour.com is that website holistic health